the pixel can't stop leaking we pretty
much know everything there is to know
about the pixel 3 as well as the pixel 3
xl we we have a very clear image now of
this pixel 3. pretty much everything
about it no matter how hard you try you
literally can't get anything past the
internet
[Applause]
so there they are
oh i think they look great
they look great right
for those of you on the live stream
please stick around to see our products
and more in-depth demos online really
appreciate you being here with us today
thank you very much have a great day
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and we
got pixel 3 and pixel 3 xl in the studio
my main sim card has been in the pixel 3
xl since the event so for two days now
and there's already a lot of stuff i
want to share with you that didn't make
it into my original video and that
wasn't in the keynote so first of all
there's many things in that first
impressions video that weren't in the
keynote and that weren't actually
mentioned so if you want the full
rundown of all the new hardware and all
the new software that was announced two
days ago that's your video definitely
watch that but that was shot two weeks
ago and there are definitely some things
now that i've set it up with my own
stuff that i'm starting to notice that i
didn't those two weeks ago when i was
using a demo phone so this isn't a
review this is more like my second first
impressions second impressions with the
pixel 3 xl so right off the bat this is
the home screen setup yes i'll drop the
wallpaper link for this guy in the
description and my impressions of the
performance right off the bat are still
that it's fast you know it's smooth
right now just like my pixel 2 was out
the box and i just have to cross my
fingers that this lasts a big question
i've had is how long will this last with
the four gigs of ram and that ties back
to the event that was easily the most
low-key part of the phone when it was
announced the specs they didn't i don't
even think they said any of the specs on
stage and that shows how much google
really thinks it matters to the average
person buying this phone but for those
who care snapdragon 845
4 gigs of ram and 64 or 128 gigs of
storage non-expandable so pretty much
baseline standard we've seen phones with
these specs from 400 to 1200 but again
if you remember the problems i had with
my pixel 2 i'll link that full video
below if you haven't seen it already uh
it's definitely got me curious how pixel
3 will hold up now the notch can't talk
about this phone without talking about
the notch uh for me so far
i've gotten used to it
but i feel like that says more about me
using phones than it does about the
phone i feel like i'm in a weird
position because i've been using phones
with notches from the oneplus 6 to the
iphone 10 and 10s and many many more for
so long that uh as i use phones now i'm
just used to ignoring a notch you might
not be in that position a lot of people
are coming from phones that don't have
notches and are trying to find a phone
to buy and this is just another one with
an even bigger than normal notch that's
not seeing it the same way but the other
reason it's easy for you to get used to
this notch when using it is because of
the way android and apps interact with
the notch or
don't interact with the notch it all
started on stage and google during the
announcement was really clever about how
they showed this display on the bigger
phone always with the sweeping angles
and hiding the notch and just overall
absolutely not embracing it and who can
blame them but then when you actually
get to start using the phone that
continues like just like every other
android phone with a big enough notch
the default seems to actually be to hide
it you pull down the notification tray
the notch is hidden
a lot of apps and stuff that use the top
of the screen apps every day i use like
spotify ignore this top notch area the
camera app totally ignores it doesn't
put any controls in the notch area just
regular rectangle waze ignores it as
well and then all the other apps that do
use the notch area are basically just
sort of color matching the huge
notification area same as other phones
it's just comically big now and some
other apps still need updating i noticed
instagram stories looks ridiculous right
now up in the top and also uh for some
reason google's own youtube studio app
is also kind of half cut off up there so
it's obviously not ideal design wise but
it just kind of is what it is also i've
seen a lot of people talk about at least
recently hiding this notch with software
so with pretty much any other android
phone with a notch you can use software
to hide it you've probably seen that you
can also technically hide this notch
though it's buried in android p's
developer settings right now but when
you enable them you can completely hide
it all the time but you lose
so much screen real estate when you do
that obviously because the notch is so
big
it's not quite at the point where you
might as well just use a smaller phone
but it's close i mean i guess the
screen's still bigger so you're gonna be
fine but people are gonna do this you
can also uh add another notch at the
bottom if you're just really into the
pain of it hey you do you man so
basically to round up my perspective on
a notch before the review but at least
right now i actually said this on sam
sheffer's podcast recently as well i'll
link that below
as a person that's just using the phone
just scrolling around swiping
notifications tweeting email or whatever
you're just numb to the notch at this
point i don't really see it anymore it's
just like every other phone with a notch
uh but when i become a video person like
a youtuber or a viewer and i'm just
pointing a camera at it then it's this
horrible ugly thing of course you see
the notch it's hideous it's massive it's
that bathtub it's a face
staring back at you that you can't
ignore
but that's when i'm in that youtuber
mode but when i'm actually using the
phone i don't find myself uh complaining
about it that much
okay a couple other small things the
haptic engine on the pixel 3 is much
improved right now i would even say it's
the best i've felt in an android phone
and i think google knows it they trigger
it more often like almost all the time
you feel it when pulling down the
notification tray
every little tap you get it while typing
while interacting with the ui a lot and
it's pretty good it's nice and clicky
and really tight
night sight in the camera it's not here
yet it's coming soon with a software
update but i have taken some night shots
without night mode and they're already
pretty great so night sight is hopefully
going to be impressive if it's anything
like that comparison they showed on
stage i'm really curious to see how that
works out but speaking of direct
comparisons that was a direct shot fired
a comparison to the iphone 10s on stage
which was recently announced which is
interesting to me but i do plan on doing
my own direct comparison with the camera
of the iphone 10s versus the pixel 3
versus probably samsung galaxy note 9 or
whatever the best samsung camera is and
then toss in one or two others maybe red
hydrogen maybe whatever huawei's coming
out with let me know what you guys want
to see but hopefully that'll be
interesting to see if you can tell the
difference between the best camera
smartphones at the end of 2019. anyway
on pixel 3 there's also now in the
camera app a raw plus jpeg option which
is awesome so if you're slowing down a
bit and really trying to take some great
shots you can turn it on and get raw
image files and go straight into editing
those you can do lightroom or whatever
app you use i love seeing that baked
into the stock camera app of a phone
that knows it's going to be used for
photography and i also noticed that in
the youtube app if i go into full screen
mode it plays off center on the pixel 3
xl it cuts off the area to one side the
size of the notch and then cuts off the
other area on the other side also the
size of the notch so it's kind of
annoying now that it's off center to be
honest the best alternative would be
having the notch cutting into the video
and then losing also some of the top and
the bottom
so i guess i'll deal with it being sort
of off center but they could totally
adjust that in a software update anyway
that's it for now just a super quick
second first impressions uh can't go too
in depth but the full review is coming
soon so definitely subscribe to see that
to be among the first when it comes out
if you haven't already but until the
next one thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace